good evening mr. president hello Janine
all right mr. president welcome to
justice I saw yesterday Good Friday that
you had Bishop Harry Jackson in the Oval
Office and you spent a great deal of
time talking about religion as you turn
to reflection and prayer in your own
relationship with God during this holy
week
what is your prayer and what is your
message of faith for Americans well I
love the people of our country and we
are bringing our country back I want to
pay my deepest love and respect to all
of the families and friends of those who
perished so sadly it was so incredible
how it came upon us this invisible I
call it this invisible enemy and it's
just a terrible thing we were doing
things that this country had never done
before in terms of our success and that
will we'll rebuild it again we're going
to rebuild it again in honor of all
those who perished
Janene well you know as Christians
around the world I mean celebrate
tomorrow which will be the holiest day
of the year for them I mean it is it is
the beginning it is a new life for many
Christians I mean do you see America
coming to a point where when we do
reopen it will be a renaissance for us
as well well I think we have a really
great chance of that where we're working
very hard with Congress on stimulus and
taking care of our workers and taking
care of people whose fault this was not
and we're doing very well the Paycheck
plan as you know is moving along quickly
that's the workers of companies there
we're loaning money to companies they're
able to pay their workers it's a it's a
thing that's doing really well and it'll
be very shortly a lot of money is going
to be given to employees we have to keep
it all together but a lot of things are
happening and I think the stimulus
coupled with this pent up demand and
everybody wanting to get out and go back
to work I think we're going to have a
just a tremendous surge I think it's
going to be a like a rocket ship I
really believe that we'll have to see
what happens
but there's a lot of things happening
but you know with all of that we still
have to remember all of the people that
perished we did it we did it the right
way we we took care of social distancing
and all of the things words that nobody
ever heard before frankly and phrases
but if we didn't do that if we would
have pulled through it you could have
had you know there were estimates 2.2
million people well if you cut that in
more than half and you said a million
and cut that in half you say 500,000 it
just would have been unacceptable so
we've all had to go through a lot the
people of our country have gone through
a lot but we did it the the right way
and we look like we'll be coming in on
the very very low side really below the
lowest the lowest side of the curve of
death that it's a horrible thing but a
lot of pain in the country a lot of a
lot of great great serious pain but
we'll be back bigger and better and
stronger than ever before you watch all
right and in my last question because I
know I know you're short on time and we
appreciate all that you're doing for us
but you have indeed delivered the
largest economic relief package in
American history you've sent cargo
planes around the globe and and you've
even had ventilators made that are as I
understand it now going back to the sock
pile you feel an obligation to help
those around the world as well as
Americans why is that well I do well
helping Italy we're helping Spain we're
helping other countries as much as we
can and now with time you know we're
building thousands of ventilators which
is so desperately needed but with all of
the things that we've done you look at
New York where we did the Javits Center
plus we sent in the ship the great ship
to comfort and you look at all of the
things that we've done it's been
incredible now I have to say that the
good news is there are very few people
now at the Javits Center there are very
few people going into the ship hospital
ship and we're sending doctors now we're
taking the doctors from those areas
sending them all over New York City now
the the what they've done
with the Army Corps of Engineers FEMA
and everybody in the federal
government's been incredible actually
they've done an incredible job well and
and being president mr. president is is
not certainly an easy job and I know you
said that the decision that you make
regarding reopening the the country is
probably the hardest decision that
you've ever been called to make when you
make that decision I mean where do you
go within you what is it that you dig
deep for to come up with a decision
aside from all of the people surrounding
you
well Janine I think it's going to be the
toughest decision that I've ever made
you know I really hopefully that I ever
will have to make but it's certainly the
toughest decision that I've ever made
and I hope that I'm going to make the
right decision I'll be basing it on a
lot of a lot of very smart people a lot
of professionals doctors and business
leaders there are a lot of things that
go into a decision like that and it's
going to be it's going to be based on a
lot of facts and a lot of instinct also
whether we like it or not there is a
certain instinct to it but we have to
get our country back people want to get
back they want to get back to work we
have to bring our country back and so
I'll be making a decision reasonably
soon we're setting up a council now of
some of the most distinguished leaders
in virtually every field including
politics and business and medical and
we'll be making that decision fairly
soon okay all right what mr. president
we agreed on a very short interview and
I I thank you very much for joining our
viewers on justice tonight and the the
the job that you have is one that all of
us certainly can't imagine but our
thoughts and and our prayers are with
you as you make this decision for all of
us in America god bless mr. president
thank you very much thank you Janine